XQC's got the most insane take on this. You're already shooting
fish in a barrel if you're rich, famous, and targeting teenagers.
Can you just not lie? We're like he's wrong on something and
he cannot let it go and he's going to try to cope in the funniest
way. If you guys are losing on the Pokimane filter, you're going
to really struggle in life.
So, Pokimane addresses the Sliker
We can check this out. All right. And then XQC asks, "Who are
the victims in this case? Please elaborate on victims of what?"
@pokimane lol >> Because in reality, behind this mirage,
this illusion, there was a master manipulator, a serial cheater,
and a predator. Someone who would make it a point for many years
to target smaller content creators, take full advantage of the
fact that he was one of the most desirable men in the streaming
world, all while making it seem like he had no experience with
women, and that it just might be romantic. They just might be
that special someone who can fix him. >> So, Pokimane addresses
the Sliker
>> We can just get it over with, okay?
Stop making me laugh. Stop laughing cuz when you guys laugh,
I laugh.
It's o- It's okay. We can just get it out of the way. All right.
>> Get it out of the way, girl. >> before streaming
today, I expected
a lot
people in the chat asking me to talk about the Sliker situation.
Oh my gosh, I I was thinking about it. I was like, >> People,
I'm telling you, this is like the easiest filter. If you guys
are losing on the Pokimane filter, you're going to really struggle
in life. Is it If you're upset by Pokimane, if she if she really
you up, if you get super mad, super ass mad listening,
I'm telling you, you're getting filtered. You're not going to
make it. It's like the lowest level filter. >> But you
know why? How can I say something that feels honest to me, but
doesn't get clipped out of context.
I was really stressed about it. And then I realized >> I
totally respect Pokimane's struggle. I respect what she's going
through here, the process, that she's in a really challenging
situation that nobody can really understand. I'm empathetic to
this situation. I get it, queen. I get it. It's tough. It's It's
tough to understand. It really is. >> I was like
I'm stressing about it so much.
And Sykkuno hasn't even said anything
>> And he hasn't responded. >> Something about that
like didn't really sit right with me, but I do want to reiterate
it's just so sad and
>> how often this kind of thing seems to happen, especially
when it comes from
people that you don't expect it to come from. And um I think
what I really want to say is I am just so so sorry for all the
hurt that's been caused.
>> In the world, really. Like Sykkuno
Israel's ethnic cleansing of Lebanon. Just there's a lot of pain
in the world and Pokimane feels it and she doesn't like it. I
get it. I get it. >> to our communities. I feel like I
feel everyone's hurt and shock and confusion.
I'm right there with you. >> It's like she's just like
one of us. She's like a normal person who totally gets it. What
a relatable girl. What a relatable
Love to see it. >> really try so hard to make my channel
a safe space for everybody.
>> Lord knows that's >> hope that people that do
need to speak up will. And hopefully
hopefully that's hopefully that's enough to help them. >> Dude.
Dude. Dude. Dude. Just I I feel like I feel like I can watch
her hand movements here and know that this will trigger people.
Just watch her hands. Watch what she does with her body language
as she talks through this, >> And hopefully
hopefully that's hopefully that's enough addressing it. >> Oh,
no. No. It didn't didn't slow down. Hold on. >> I really
try so hard
to make
my channel
>> This right here, this with her hands, the gesticulation.
>> a safe space
for everybody.
>> Try for everybody.
I really hope the people that
do need to speak up
>> Will. And then she finishes and she claps her hands
back together. This is where I was talking about. Claps.
Looks incredibly self-satisfied
with the situation,
right? She claps and she's just like you can see with the the
lips even, okay? That face. That face I can just I see that face
and I can picture perfectly every single wall that TechTone punched
a hole in in his house just from seeing that face. He sees that
face and he immediately just starts smashing holes in drywall,
just putting him his arm up to the elbow in drywall. I can feel
it and it gives me happiness. It like actually sustains me. Just
knowing how people react to Poki, okay? It just it's so nice.
You're doing God's work.
>> And [snorts] hopefully
hopefully that's hopefully that's enough addressing it.
But I do appreciate how kind everyone in the chat has been. So,
thank you so much for that. >> And that's really the big
She's really When you think about it, she is something of a victim
herself, okay? She was close to Sakuuna. She is something of
a victim herself. So, you go from this to The only victims are
his girlfriend for being cheated on and Sykkuno for false accusers
labeling him a and a predator. Shut the [__] up you
I mean, no, Sykkuno is not labeled a Nobody Nobody has watched
this. Who thinks SYKKUNO IS A
WHO THINKS SYKKUNO IS A
WHO? NOBODY. YOU'RE JUST PROJECTING.
He's just totally projecting. Is a victim the moment Sykkuno
enters the replies? Actually quite true. Okay. Then XQC quote
tweets this and says, "Who are the victims in this case? Please
elaborate on the victims of what? Or please elaborate on victims
of what?"
And Poki actually comes back and has a response to this. Hold
on. You realize people People can be victims of cheating, right?
Well, I think I think she's trying to say the women who were
lied to and manipulated could be victims as well. Using lingo
that's used for predators and groomers and for cheaters kind
of crazy, no? Just because that's the context you hear it in
doesn't mean it's the only one. Victim, one that is acted on
One that is acted on and usually adversely affected by a force
or agent. So check Yes.
Obviously. 11k likes for that tweet. Yeah. Still not ratioing
the queen
Not even close. Except you said victims, which is plural, which
implies multiple. So besides Zex, who is / are the other victims?
Clearly there's more than one girl he was speaking to and likely
others thought they were exclusive. Y'all are fighting over semantics
when there's a larger problem here. Oh my god. Absolute queen
Absolute queen She is actually She is actually correct. She is
totally correct and everybody's getting super ass mad about it.
Let's Oh. Let's
All right, this is And she picks her battles. Where Where ever,
okay? Where has she ever like gone to Twitter and actually fought
on one of these clips? That's why I don't think she's rage baiting
in this situation, right? Sometimes she's totally rage baiting,
but not in this situation. I think in this situation she's actually
like sort of she's standing her business, right? In other situations
I think she's rage baiting. She doesn't go to have an argument,
but this time she's like, "No, this is a problem."
And this is why she's popular influencer with women. This is
why. This is exactly it, okay? So without further ado we can
finally go to the video I wanted to watch from the very beginning,
which is Asmongold reacting to this with an xQc reaction cuz
I need to see xQc's face when he hears that Asmongold turned
on him, okay? Maybe we'll watch the Asmon reaction first. Give
me a second. Pokimane did talk about the Sliker no thing. I I
I I Why does he have the clip up? Why does he have this clip
up? Why does he have to Oh, right. This was what she posted to
like sub tweet about it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. This is what she posted
to sub tweet about it. This was This is her sub tweet post. It
was like um right when it happened. How it feels
How How it sounds to feel disappointed but no longer surprised.
We have to see >> Do we have to see this? For all the people
who are currently holding a stable occupation, Sliker no was
one of the most popular streamers on Twitch. The dude initially
looked like this and this. Then he changed his whole persona
to that of an insecure soft-spoken twink and built up A LITERAL
>> DUDE, I KNOW THIS EDITOR IS LIKE A NAZI, but he always
cooks. Every single time this cooks, okay?
Every without fail this editor. I understand that he's like a
terrible He's got terrible politics, but holy This guy cooks
every time. >> harem of girls while also cheating on his
girlfriend. Pokimane was one of his closest friends and now they're
all switching up on him. Some going as far as calling him a predator.
>> I'll just We can just get it over with, okay? Of course
before streaming today I expected a lot of people in the chat
asking me to talk about the Sliker no situation. Poki [laughter]
>> Yeah, I get it. >> lot of people in the chat asking
>> I'll never ask people to not have this reaction to Pokimane
saying literally nothing with a lot of words. Uh I'll never have
I'll never say you can't have this reaction. It's just if you
get really angry about it afterwards, okay? That's when I'm like
very concerned for you. You can have this reaction cuz she is
in fact saying nothing with a lot of >> need to talk about
the Saikou no situation. How can I say something that feels honest
to me, but doesn't get clipped out of context?
>> I was really stressing about it and then I realized
like >> Oh, here we are. >> I'm stressing about it
so much and Saikou no hasn't even said anything. >> Probably
you should >> You going to respond to the allegations?
>> Yeah, anyway, so we're going to play >> Dude,
his chat. He is like not leaning into his chat. His chat is so
[__]
Dude, hold on. Where's uh Holy hell, she's she something.
She farm axing.
Mental illness photo child. Guy being a guy Oh, man, she actually
look old now.
Wait, what? Okay, never mind. That one That one's out of pocket.
What? >> even said anything. >> Just all of all of
this like She's so fake, bro. Thousand pounds of makeup. Dude,
they hate Poki so much. It's very funny. Probably you should
You going to respond to the allegations? No. >> Yeah, anyway,
so we're going to play Minecraft today. >> Guess what girl
just started an OnlyFans less than 2 weeks ago. These chicks
will use a dude's cheating on them as advertisement for their
nude pics. So, wait a minute. You're telling me that one of the
girls that was talking to Saikou no just started an OnlyFans
right before this exposé. That's >> with a $600 tier. That's
the he mom girl and she was like, well, I'm not necessarily cutting
you out.
>> That he mom girl, I'm telling you totally psychotic.
She might have a point that maybe there's something but totally
psychotic. Like and it doesn't take away from the allegation
and what's shown in the document, but she's like totally psychotic
and it's very funny to me. It's It's crazy. Crazy. >> I
think what I really want to say is I am just so >> Dude,
speaking of farm axing.
Just this face this transition between the eyes going over here?
This is like a face he's mastered doing like at the drop of a
hat. He just immediately does this. He's worked on this in the
mirror a lot.
Okay. Oh, I'm muted. Whoops. >> What I really want to say
is I am just so so sorry for all the hurt that's been caused
to the victims to our communities. I feel like I feel everyone's
hurt and shock and confusion.
>> It's like um Yeah, Zizi. It's like people think if you
can attack the woman and this works and I just wish we could
break the pattern of this working on like totally brain damaged
I unfortunately I I say incels. It's like it's not even necessarily
incel. It's just there's not a better word. There needs to be
a better word cuz I'm sure some of these people have relationships.
But it's like when you get this this like totally performative
rage when somebody's accused of something. Like you feel like
personally
It's very very strange to me. Like you you don't look at any
information. You're just immediately looking for how you could
discredit and attack the woman in the situation.
It's like hey, we could do that. We could get to that. It's just
not going to make the other person innocent like ever. The other
person doesn't become innocent because you figured out that the
person accusing them is a piece of [__] It's not
how it works, man.
You know? >> It's also Pokimane with Nina and a couple
months ago. >> just unbanned after less than 2 days and
now people have found out she was streaming with Pokimane earlier
this month. For context, the assault incident was months back.
>> My type is the obeying type. Um any any obeying? Certainly
you need to. Your wallet is my wallet. My wallet. My wallet.
Yeah, any girl we talk to about to be your sister or your mom
or dad, don't talk to them too much either. >> People have
preferences? >> It's for breeding purposes only. >> For
breeding purposes? >> I Again, this was months after she
assaulted the guy. >> And I think this is something that
I think a lot of other people have been frustrated by. When you
use mediums meant for calling out predators and you use hyper
language to describe those things, I think it diminishes the
term a little bit and it's frustrating and I think it's frustrating
>> I have to agree with I I'm agreeing with >> I
I'm trying to think of I differ a little bit and we watched this
already earlier in the stream. If you guys are just seeing it
for the first time, I
Okay, so yeah, he does agree with
I don't know that there's something wrong with predator being
like diminished in some way. I think basically when you're looking
into these things, you should always be looking at the actual
allegations, right? And that if you want to understand what's
going on somewhere, you should try to look at
what what just look for what was done. What the actual allegations
are. You're just looking at like a four-word title, a five-word
title, you're obviously not getting a good explanation. You shouldn't
be putting that much weight on the title. >> that to predatory,
the word predatory means a little bit more more. >> not
fair in making use of his status and lying about his virginity
and lack of experience. If lying about your virginity and lack
of experience, who do you guys think does that more, men or >> you
had >> Oh, just such a bad argument.
And also, I do think what I pointed out before was with with
people mocked the [__] out of Akash for his wife
lying to him. Everybody acts like his wife is a demon for lying
about being a in college, right? Every Who didn't have a negative
opinion of her explicitly for that? Literally everybody called
her out for that, for lying about it. Literally everybody was
upset about that. It's a bad thing. Anyway. >> Had to guess.
>> Are all those women that do that >> What are the
people that are close to him having takes that green light dog
labels that damage him severely and I'm the outsider, the voice
of reason saying, "Guys, I don't think he's a predator." What
the [__] is that? That's >> Like those are
the kinds of people if like the social opinion of a person like
that turns, they will turn with it. They have no actual loyalty
because they're not real people, they're brands. So, I will say
this does not apply to the one guy in this situation, the other
OTK guy, who is like actually viable. The other OTK guys are
like totally non-viable, right? Like all of them. Sorry, not
OTK, OTV. OTV I meant. The other OTV members like Abe and um
Abe and the other guy. I'm sorry, I hate to say it to those guys,
but they're totally non-viable, right?
Toast is the other guy who's like viable in some way, and he
came out. Scar is the other one, yeah. Toast came out. Disguised
Toast came out and said, "This but I ain't dumping this or so,
good luck. Good luck everybody with your with your campaigns
here." No, Disguised Toast came out and said,
"Listen, it's really what he did." And I think that's the appropriate
response. Uh "Sykkuno allegations are so black pilling. A big
streamer is the boyfriend and a bunch of idiots accuse him of
being a predator instead of just telling people he's a cheater,
resulting in everyone having to defend him. Meanwhile, his cheated
on girlfriend gets nothing." Well, hey, one of the
Or you could just handle them
What? I just don't understand. Why do you think This is just
a like a differentiation of priorities. Why do you think people
are like thinking he's a Like who actually thinks he's a
And then, why do you feel like that's your first priority going
into this?
That's like, "Oh, the actual the biggest
the biggest
most important thing to focus on here is the fact that this guy
is not a
Oh, why? Okay, I get it. I didn't get the impression that this
girl was accusing him of being a racist.
Didn't his girlfriend greenlight this
I don't know about that. I
And here's the thing, in my head, the way I took like a lot of
this in was through the lens of like Mujin really validating
a lot of this, and I don't know if the girlfriend is actually
down with any of this. I know the girlfriend was talking to to
Mal because that is in the DMs. When Mal recorded the video,
the the girl who recorded the call with Sykkuno, she goes to
a group chat where she doesn't censor she doesn't censor it and
it leaks the name of Sykkuno's
Okay? So, the girlfriend was involved, the girlfriend was talking,
but I don't know that the girlfriend was a part of the Mujin
piece or green-lit or was okay with the Mujin piece at all. It's
entirely possible she wasn't.
And I I would have thought that as Mujin you you like actually
check into that and make sure. >> that was part of the
exposé just started her only fans. There is a little bit of a
silver lining. >> And I'm dying from the cringe. What is
>> Well, you're actually so much braver than I thought.
>> Only cuz you're here. >> Oh my god. Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ.
>> And the thing is that anybody that's going to meme on
him >> saying anything bad about that, it worked. So, again,
>> It literally didn't work. LilyPichu
I'm
If anything, LilyPichu is the inverse, okay? Okay, now we're
going to go to xQc's reaction. We didn't get this part. This
is new. So, this is Asmongold when he goes and watches the xQc
versus
Pokimane tweets that we pulled up
Asmongold actually
Oh, I hate to spoil it a little bit, but Asmongold actually takes
the correct
He he he ain't [__] with xQc's stupid >> Who
are the victims of this case? Please elaborate on victims. What?
I I mean, I I I disagree with this. I actually disagree with
xQc on this. I think that somebody >> He thinks he's debating
Asmongold. >> is a victim of a manipulator, a person who
leads them on, who gives them the false impression, and who intentionally
tries to take advantage of that impression that they don't have.
Like and I don't think that that like if you if you want to argue
>> That's like Asmongold is almost he's almost hitting
it bar for bar. Now, the really funny thing to check into will
be Asmongold's reaction to whatever X xQc's disagreement is and
are any of the the Asmongold sucks who went the entirely other
direction and said Pokimane was a totally disgusting hag for
her opinion, are they going to switch up at all? Cuz I think
Asmongold's actually going to nail it here.
And I don't know what those people I it'd be very funny to track
opinions. I was not tracking it that closely, so I don't know
for sure. Michael Reeves is 28 years old? What? That guy looks
12. Are you about the
Then who are the victims then of what? Well, I mean he didn't
he didn't he Well, I mean he didn't answer. Much of Jai said
he didn't agree, but >> He literally did answer. There's
only one
There's only one group of people Hold on. There's literally only
one group of people who were lied to and manipulated and given
a false impression. Well, sorry, maybe that does technically
apply to the girlfriend, but it obviously applies to the people
who he's cheating with way more than the girlfriend. Like that's
clearly she's saying those people or sorry. Asmongold's saying
those people can be victims. Yes, they're victims of like a lesser
thing, but they're still victims. >> I It's I'm not doing
a statement. I'm I'm doing Guys, I'm doing a question.
>> I mean again, I think that categorically victim is the
right word to use, but they're not victims of a crime.
And also somebody says in chat, "The biggest victim of all of
this is his
She is the biggest victim of all of it.
>> Wait, what?
Wait, what? Oh, yeah, xQc's Dude, xQc's got the most insane take
on this.
Bro, this guy's got to fix He's got that illness in him that
a lot of streamers have who are super who are like massive narcissists.
Where like he's wrong on something and he cannot let it go and
he's going to try to cope in the funniest way. It's it's rough,
okay? He's going to try to cope in the funniest way because
listen to how he describes why Asmongold is wrong. He goes,
"Wrong. You're wrong when you say that Asmongold. She's not the
biggest victim. Here's why." >> Again, oh I mean again,
then I absolutely disagree. Because because we
do not know. Okay, no no.
I agree that the posts made may make her a victim, but I'm not
going to assume in the blind that she is a victim because we
don't know what the >> Okay, now I'm listening to this
again.
Listen, maybe I maybe my translator broke for a second before.
So, he's saying that according to what's out now, she would be
a victim. And he's saying, "But we don't know." Which is just
a stupid argument to make. Of course, until he updates
like everybody knows that he could come out with some stuff,
but it's like low-grade given the amount of evidence that's out
given that literally his girlfriend is in a DM that's already
leaked saying
obviously
that she can't look at this anymore. She feels ill looking at
it. She doesn't want to know anymore about like how much she
was cheated. Obviously, she's like devastated to hear about this,
okay?
That's in the that's already been
So, it's not like there's something else going on. I mean, the
the hypothetical he comes up with is ludicrous. He's like basically
saying, "You know, we don't know beyond a shadow of a doubt."
And it's like, dude, nobody's going to require that. It's internet
drama. Nobody's going to require that. >> The nature of
the relationship is we don't know. And anybody who claims that
they know are absolutely lying. >> Let me tell you how
this works. >> this instance, right? >> Okay, let's
say >> that both these partners both cheat on each other
every day. They both do it. And let's say that in a
she did it 10 times and he did it twice. But it's it's what they
do though, right? It's the >> So, dude. Hypothetically,
what if she was cheating a whole bunch more than he was cheating
and you just don't know about that yet? Okay, why would we Why
are you inventing scenarios in which this guy is not the Or sorry,
is the victim.
What? Like How tell
How do you explain just totally projecting here like this? Like
I guarantee you xQc is just thinking of some situation he was
in that he couldn't speak up during. And it's like, dude, just
talk about it. Why are you coming up with random scenarios that
have nothing to do with this one?
And going like, hypothetically, there's some world where you
could invent a narrative where he's not really a bad person and
he's the victim
Okay. Why are you doing that? Why would you do that? I don't
understand why you're doing that. Very strange.
Very odd. >> nature of their relationship, right?
>> In this context, right?
Nobody really is the victim. And if if there is a victim it would
be more of him. True or false?
even though we don't know we don't know
we have no information about the case. We have no information
about the relationship. We have We don't know what they do. We
don't know what their standings are. We don't know what they
have been doing. >> We actually do know. And actually,
Psychudo has apologized to multiple women now about Now, maybe
maybe we give xQc the benefit of the doubt and say he didn't
know about the second set of apologies. But he's apologized to
everybody and has never once denied that he cheats on his girlfriend.
Even in private. So, like we we've heard about it. We know she's
devastated. Like she acted like she didn't know. The document
claims she didn't know.
The Psychudo says that she's blindsided. Yeah, she's mad. Yeah,
okay, whatever, right? Everybody Everybody except xQc.
Literally everybody agrees on this except for xQc and I don't
get it.
It's wild. >> So, why would I assume
that when we have a no information except for uh third parties
who all are doing this for profit, why why would I
uh now
>> elaborate on why as an outsider I should >> So,
so [laughter] third-party thing. I would you finish xQc 104 IQ.
>> I assume >> These people suck.
>> Bro, his chat his chat's less supportive of him than
you guys are of me. This is
What the hell? >> Why as an outsider I should assume
that one
cheating occurred. Two, it's it's it's some cheating that that
is that is uncommon to them that that's that that that that >> Disappointed
motorbike rider. >> Because I don't know.
Why would why would I assume >> He didn't have to assume.
I I opened up this way when I first started watching the video.
And then they show that the girlfriend was like in these group
Well, they say that the girlfriend was in the group chats. You
do see evidence that the girlfriend was in the group chats. You
do see evidence that this girl was showing their her relationship
to Sykkuno
and that Sykkuno was talk Sorry, that she was talking to multiple
women
had sort of problems with Sykkuno.
I I don't even know like And it Listen, it's possible
with the current information, I think it's totally reasonable
to assume Sykkuno was was the cheater and that she his girl his
girlfriend was not doing the same thing.
If he wants to come out with a bunch of information showing his
evidence, showing his like reasoning or showing that he
in fact did
like less cheating, then we all flip immediately. But, he has
to come out with that. >> is that this guy was playing
around doing this, disrespecting her the entire
So, that's my opinion. Like, I don't think there's anything wrong
with him having this perspective because victim can imply a crime.
It's the same perspective that I have. Like, he thinks the same
way about it as I I see predator. So, if he sees victim that
way, that's fine. I don't see I I I have a more broad definition
of the term. And I think that like Saikono did take advantage
of people. He did do things that were in bad faith. >> to
the point where they're only betraying a partner and still continue
without ending things. It doesn't matter the situation, uh just
wrong. >> Okay. Okay, they're not. They're not. So,
how how do you know this is what occurred? How do you know? >> Saikono
chat. >> You guys are living in like fan fiction. Where
you you're you're portraying yourself as
>> It's like a really really bad Destiny impression. Is
that what xQc stream is now? He just does a really bad Destiny
impression most of most of the time. I don't It's actually crazy.
What you guys don't understand is you're just like making this
up. I No. You're just not It's fine. >> you did it in the
shoes of the girlfriend. Like, you know all the all the all the
components. You know, bro, we don't know that. >> Heartbreaking.
The worst people you know are fighting.
>> Guys, we don't know that. >> According to her
logic, then Fuslie is a predator, right? No, it's wife is a victim
of Fuslie. >> He made the [__] >> If a
girl talked to multiple men and cheated on them, everyone would
call her out and move on. >> This is why we have the court
of the
>> Because we don't know you. The
>> There's maybe there's another thing that contributes
to people not being able to evaluate the situation correctly.
But like just the way gender dynamics work, you essentially will
never get a woman who does this same thing.
Like this it it's just not a plausible situation or scenario.
I would apply the same principles, but there just isn't like
a woman will never do this precise thing. >> Girl talked
to multiple men and cheat on them and everyone would call her
a hoe. >> This is why we have the court of the
>> No, it's not. This is not Nothing happened that was
illegal here. What do you mean this is why we have the court
of the law?
This is not what the court of the law is
>> Or and move on. Stri- >> This is why we have the
court of the
>> Because we don't know you know, the nature of that call,
right? We don't know what the nature of that call is. This is
somebody who was recording in private, who's going to post this
later on, right?
It could be cycle trying to wiggle himself out of that stupid
ass call, right? It it gives him >> He proposed the call.
He literally asked her to call and then he called.
He said, "I need to talk to you. I'm going to call you." He called
and then they talked.
>> Just a vision. We don't know >> Like Like that's
the problem with By the way, I say it bad at Destiny's impression
cuz at least Destiny, from what I recall, would remember the
facts of what was going on. XQC is just like forgetting things
conveniently to make the argument he wants to make. It's very
weird. >> How would that play Like you guys are making
so many assumptions that's stupid. Like I don't know what people
do this they they they kind of all
nobody's defending cheating.
cheating is one thing and if that if that was some some outline
cheating, then there would be one victim of that cheating. That's
it. Who are the victims? Like how was I wrong? Who are the victims?
Go ahead, say it.
Now say it. Now >> By the way, so some people I think I
think this is Dickers was arguing that you could just call this
like a cheating drama. This is why you can't cuz I do think I
do think a lot like I think broadly when you say it's a cheating
drama, you assume it's like one victim. You assume it's different
than what it is. And they are a they are alleging and feel hurt
by the broader pattern of behavior that affects more than one
Anyway, we continue. >> Wait, who are the victims with
an S at the end? No, I didn't say victim. I said victims. Like
she said it.
I'd say that only one and would be
In my there's only one victim, right? And
Now watch this. Chat, let me ask you let me ask you this. What
if what if it was a polyamorous relationship? Let's say let's
say it was. >> Dude, how hard is this guy getting filtered?
Your main problem is the cheating and leading women on, right?
Uh well, I mean my main problem from the very beginning
was that this guy is like he disgusts me. He threw every like
red flag up instantly within 2 seconds of hearing his voice.
I like hated this guy immediately when I saw this. When I when
I first heard him speak. So, that's like the that's problem one,
okay? And then once we actually got to these allegations, problem
two was yeah, I I do think there's a couple different things.
It's the system it's the systematic nature where he's doing it
over and over again with multiple women. It's the
it's using the
Basically he uses what is a power imbalance to establish a relationship
a rapport with these women in a way that he's trying to act overtly
friendly. And then by using that like friendliness
he gets them comfortable and is consistently going to try to
push it to a thing like after that. Like he asked them to meet
up in person and then he does try to make like a move. I I do
think it feels like very weird. Now, I will say it doesn't seem
like he just cuts women off when they don't get
Right? It's I think.
So, it's like I don't know maybe maybe it's not quite like that
and maybe we just have a really bad but it it seemed like when
he was trying to get he was consistently talking about how one
he was either down playing it like he wasn't or two he was talking
about how we could have something longer term.
And I think that lying, not being up front about what you want
is what I dislike. So, basically establish establishing the connection
using your existing reputation
and then you meet these women. You're like you're you're giving
them gifts, which I I think is mostly neutral to me. Right? He's
not like he's giving them gifts for stuff. They describe problems,
he gives them money. I think that's like neutral. I have no problem
I don't take that as like massive manipulation. It could be,
but again, it's like it doesn't seem like I'm positive there
are women who got money from him and never gave him anything
and he didn't like on them or start rumors about them. If you
find out about that, then he is like
extremely like he's bad. He needs to go. But um yeah, it's just
it's the systematic like manipulative nature
that feels like he is predating on specific people. Like and
again, the focus on his community on like Vtubers like the smaller
smaller Twitch streamers, smaller It seemed like a lot of Vtubers
had him in DMs.
I bet you think Mick Mick Jagger was being manipulative, too,
huh? No, in fact, Michiko, it was literally if you were here
earlier and also had an IQ above 100, you would have understood
that I pointed this out as something that's explicitly not bad.
In fact, that when you go when groupies go to meet the band,
they don't have a long-standing relationship with the band where
the band has been buying the groupie gifts and some band members
been buying them gifts and saying we're going to be together
forever and then they and then they leave town. No, the groupie
shows up, wants to
and goes home and the band keeps
No, I don't think Mick Jagger's like this at all cuz ain't nobody
thought Mick Jagger was looking for something
He was, in fact, in more ways than one, a Rolling Stone. And
no, Michiko, that's the opposite of what's happening here. And
I feel like you're not paying attention or listening at all.
He was doing the opposite of that. He was saying we're He was
building a relationship. He was trying to make them feel something
else. He was trying to and he would even not even So, he wouldn't
tell them he was in a relationship, he'd say he doesn't [__]
anybody else, right? He would do everything to make it seem like
he focuses on them, they're special, and that he wants something
with them. And then he would try to ask you escalate to and he
obviously with a girlfriend had no intention of ever following
through on those things. That's the problem. Sorry, maybe you
just haven't been here. I love you Michiko. I love you. I I don't
mean to yell at I'm sorry I said you were low IQ. I I do that
all the time. >> They were dating and I don't know why.
I'm not going to assume but you're assuming you're assuming that
it wasn't. I'm not assuming that it isn't but you're assuming
that it wasn't. So we're both equally wrong in that way. That's
why I don't I'm not making assumptions, you are. Guys guys, I
think Ice Poseidon is wrong about this. I think he's just wrong.
>> He told things that were knowingly lies and he did that
in a way that was not becoming Well, hold on. I think I think
sleeping with groupies is still bad but you're not wrong that
it is more clear in expectations. No, I think it it's probably
fine.
Like Sorry, it's fine to the degree that
you know, at some point
groupies are like a part of capitalism in a way, okay?
Like that's a huge part of the drive to become like truly great
at something is that you get to all of the you do you get to
year olds, okay? That is like a part of the drive of becoming
great is you get to 18 year olds. I'm just saying you're already
you're already shooting fish in a barrel if you're rich, famous,
and targeting teenagers. Can you just not lie? Couldn't you just
be You're already shooting fish in a barrel. You already have
the easiest time in the world. Could you just not lie to them,
too? Is that so much to ask? What? No, come on, that's bad. No,
I don't think I think the power imbalance is there but
but then when you're not using that power imbalance, when you're
not lying to them and like manipulating them to make them think
like take their guard down cuz that's the thing is a bunch of
these women probably are actually looking for some kind of relationship.
And they're fine with having sex with somebody that is going
to build to something but they don't want to do that outside
of that. So when they say when the one girl says like, "Hey,
I want to know that there's like we're going to have a relationship
if there's something more here. And he goes, "Yeah, I'm not in
a relationship and yeah, I'm like interested and we I want you
to maybe move in with me and stuff." When he's doing all that,
right?
When he's doing all that, that's different. That's like actually
establishing the relationship through the power dynamic and then
trying to take down the defenses, the not give them what they
want. It's like, "Dude, you're you're doing a trade deal, okay?"
This is Code of Hammurabi [__]
If you have bad intentions going into a trade deal, that's bad.
If you are intending to lie and dishonestly, in bad faith, make
a trade of some kind, that's bad. That is always bad. That is
a fundamental part of society is calling that out, saying that
is awful. Don't do that. Right?
So, obviously in this situation, I feel like calling it out.
I feel like it's bad, obvious. You're right? It's not even close.
It's not manipulating them into Yes, it
It is manipulating them into It is manipulative. It's I'm not
going to do the by deception thing, but it is like it's the same
moral wrong at a lesser scale as most of the by deception arguments.
This person wouldn't want to have And I don't know that that's
true, right? But it's possible they they cut it off there if
he doesn't say like yeah, I want and that's what I'm like messaging
you for.
That's all. It gives them the option. It lets everybody act with
transparency knowing what's going on. That's all. >> I'm
a man of a gentleman. >> Oh, sorry. Maybe I'm misreading
the chat. We keep going. >> And if you want to say that
people are they think sexual assault is wrong, then I think that's
valid. If people want to use a different term, that's fine. But
I don't think that it was a good thing to
>> So, that's really the way I see it. >> Then every
time that I meet somebody, every time that I see somebody that
I think said something that's inaccurate, I'm going to say that
they're predator and then that I'm a victim. And I I hope the
best for all the victims around the
>> Just no engagement at all. Like I It's bad when you're
getting lapped by on like genuinely engaging with any intellectual
topic. Like it's actually really rough when you're when you're
getting totally mogged by on intellectual engagement, that's
a That's when you throw the towel in, >> This person If
If somebody act in ways that I think are aren't uh um entirely
fully truthful, oh my god, then I'm a I'm a victim.
People have been calling him a predator. People have said People
have People have said victims. I disagree. I I think I think
it's I think it's buzzwording. I think it's awful.
>> She was only upset uh that she's not the only one. She
wanted it, he gave it. I'm not talking about the girls that he
hooked up with. I'm talking about the girl that he was actually
dating. You know, it's like you can be a victim of racism, but
it's not technically illegal. Well, sometimes, right? >> Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
He is talking about the other people. Biggest victim in all of
it. He sees victim that way as predator. It's fine.
Wait, he was explicitly talking about the other people at first,
and then he brings it back, and then he says, "I'm talking about
the girl he's dating." What did I miss from there? Cuz he was
definitely talking about the other girls at first.
>> Boom. I disagree. >> Uh that she's not the only
one. She >> thing. I think it's awful.
>> She was only upset uh that she's not the only one. She
wanted it, he gave it. I'm not talking about the girls that he
hooked up with. I'm talking about the girl that he was actually
dating. You know, it's like you can be a victim of racism, but
it's not technically
Oh, hold on. Did XQC read Asmongold? Maybe they just misunderstood
each
I can't tell I can't tell if Asmongold is not engaging cuz he's
totally correct. Everything he said there perfectly applies to
the women who were lied to. So, did he just stumble into the
correct opinion? Cuz I don't think
Categorically victim is right the right word to use, but they're
not victims of a crime. Also, the biggest victim No, he was definitely
talking about all of them Where did he change?
Yeah, okay. Hold on. What I I'm so lost on where he changed it
up. Where did he switch it up? >> You don't know sometimes,
right? But that's at least how I see it.
>> I disagree. >> XQC already this case. Please elaborate
on victims what?
I mean I I disagree with this. I actually disagree with XQC on
this. I think that somebody is a victim of a manipulator, a person
who leads them on, who gives them the false impression. >> Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, but but when did Guys, I watched the
whole video and all I saw all the all all the evidence. When
did this happen?
Show Show me where this happened. Show me where the the the >> So,
maybe did I Did we skip through it and we just didn't see the
evidence of like moving in?
Cuz I I could have sworn we did moving. Okay, so let's look at
this. Ooh, I get It can make it hard to go outside or do too
much sometimes though, lol. Or so. Oh, I get that. I'm allergic
to grass. Not as bad, but I can become really dizzy from it.
It's like the only allergy I have, lol. But if I ever come visit,
like we don't have to go always go out, you know, as long as
you're
Also, aren't pets bad for your condition? I don't know how sensitive
it is, but sometimes cat hairs can make it worse. Certain ones
can be, it depends though. My dog is fine. He's not very allergenic.
Well, my family dog that I don't get to see anymore or often
anymore, sadly. So, hypoallergenic pets are fine. Yeah, and even
some that aren't like listed as were okay, too. I mean, if they're
If I'm there anyways, we'll have to think of a name, no? Yeah,
but I don't know if I could take care of it by myself. Or were
you going to just going to name it cat? You'll have to stay to
help me take care of it.
So, that's implying that she's coming down and they're he's thinking
about adopting a cat with her. And he says, "But I can't take
care of it by myself. You'll have to stay to help me take care
of it." That like that is almost all I need to say he is fostering
a false impression in this person. No? Like I don't know what
And people can say, "Oh, he's joking there." What's the joke?
Oh, I'm okay with that. Oh, yeah, I'm okay with that. Though,
I don't know how that would work with me staying there. I can't
stay forever, either, you know, cuz I'm not an American citizen.
I'll also probably have to go back as well. Cuz I mean, I hope
at least that I can go back to studying and this year. And like,
in general, everything is expensive. Oh, yeah, that's true. Okay,
maybe we can get a cat cat together another time then. Besides,
don't you already have a cat? Yeah, but they're my dad's. Also,
did you finally order the food? LOLs.
Oh, I see. So, you wouldn't have to bring them if you just move
somewhere? No, I guess though I guess not though I'd miss them
so much, so I def have to get new pets. You know who I really
miss though? My dog. Yeah, I was so sad when I didn't see my
dog as much. Huh?
So, it's literally he's saying, "Oh, you wouldn't necessarily
have to bring your cats with you if you move somewhere." As in,
where's where's she
Going to move there. No, she's Dana. Oh, sorry, she's not Dana,
she's Dutch. I'm pretty sure. I'm pretty sure she's Dutch. So,
I'm going to be honest.
I'm not even going to cap. Okay, I'm not even I'm not even going
to cap. This is what we needed Polymarket for, okay? I want a
Polymarket
somehow so I can make a bet on this.
I think
that at some point
these two will end up dating. For real, they'll end up moving
in
Who who says no?
Who says no? Despite everything, I think they still move in together.
I'm not even joking, I think they still move in
Anybody Anybody disagree with that? Anybody think that's insane?
I
I genuinely think this guy's got some kind of complex with this
girl.
I think I think I think there's something going on cuz I have
no idea
why he picks up that phone and wants to call her and talk to
her. I think he is like sort of obsessed with her. I think he
is I think he was And maybe maybe this flips a lot. I think now,
somehow, that he was not joking here. I do think he was thinking,
"Oh, I might have to break up with my girlfriend and come move
in with this
I think so.
I mean, the end of the call gives you everything you need to
know.
Does it? I don't think it does.
Cuz everybody reads the end of that call as, "Oh, he's like saying
I'm never going to talk to you again."
That's not how I read the end of that
And I re-listened to it, and it's not how I hear the end of that
call.
I think he's throwing out a lifeline and going, "Well, I guess
we're done talking
I guess I'll never talk to you again since this is the last time
we're
I Am I I'm the only one who can hear that? Do I just have a stronger
narcissist radar than you guys or Cuz there's a lot of people
I was agreeing with that. Oh, you agree with that. Okay. Cuz
some people have been disagreeing with me on that, and they're
saying, "Oh, no, he said he tried to cut her off and said, 'No,
no, no, no, no, no.'" He doesn't want her anymore.
And I'm like, "No, that's not what I hear at the end of that
call." Now,
given what what's going on with his reputation and stuff, maybe
he doesn't want to talk to her anymore. Maybe, but I I feel like
somehow in my head I see it going the other direction, man. I
see it going the other direction. I I swear. I think I think
he's got something where he likes getting yelled at by this girl.
I don't know.
And isn't that all you really need in the world is somebody you
enjoy getting yelled at by?
I don't know. Okay. He caused more drama. So, we're watching
the xQc response to Asmongold. >> Actually copy the the
the the timestamp and let me watch it.
>> And And two intentionally tries to take advantage of
that impression that they don't have. Like I
And I don't think that that like if you if you want to argue
about the
I mean, again, I think that categorically victim is the right
word to use, but they're not victims of a
And also, somebody says in chat, "The >> I think he would
I I it's it's a it's a misunderstanding that that he would feel
like if people acted the way that people acting towards him,
and you just do those justifications to use wording and verbage
against him, he would he would 100% he would flip on this 100%.
He would flip out and be like, "Whoa, whoa, whoa. This wording
is way too strong.
That's not what it actually is. And wait, wait, wait. I didn't
say the truth >> Does he think Does he think this is a
great argument? Like, that could be true, but wouldn't that just
be him succumbing to his bias?
Like, wouldn't that just I feel like that would just be him succumbing
to the bias there? As in, like, when he's not when he's not self-inserting,
when he's not putting himself in that situation, he is saying
logically this is all how how this works.
And NxCee's like, "Yeah, but if you were like getting called
a predator, you'd really freak out." And it's like, "Okay, maybe,
but that doesn't mean he's wrong
That just means he would get emotional about it and maybe not
be able to make a correct judgment." >> entirely about
this, but that doesn't mean that I was I was I was trying to
do a ruse or whatever. That's that's outrageous. Bang. And then
he would flip on this. It's important to be on in the middle
here and just just call it out for what it is. >> NxCee's
like asking the right questions. It's just really crazy for him
to be asking these on the 14th. I feel like he's asking all the
same questions I was when this first dropped, but then they get
answered through the course of following the the drama.
Like, these are the questions I had was like, "Okay, is there
some kind of open relationship? Do we know what the status is?
Do we know how the girlfriend feels?" And then what he just asked
right here. >> It's important to be in the middle here
and just just call it out for what it is. If it's a if you're
buzz wording, you're buzz wording. So, >> Oh, that's not
what I meant. Hold on. What What did I just He just said something
else here. Oh,
word's too strong. Dude, don't greenlight what happened. I He
said something here that made me think of it. It was It was Is
there an open relationship? And then basically, "Oh, is so that
there's some malicious thing happening." It's that I think you
could see that Tycoon is malicious in the way he does this. I
think there's enough of a pattern now to know that he is lying
about having a girlfriend. He's lying about his experience with
women, right? He's trying to make it seem like he's not sleeping
around. He's He's misleading women significantly in order to
get what he wants.
I think
Yeah, I think that's right. I do think that's right. Like it's
very different from how a lot of different people would operate
here.
So, I was looking for those two things. Basically, what was the
relationship and how cuz again, I I feel like if there was some
plausible deniability and I could go, "Well, I think Sykkuno
really wanted to be with all of these women." Right? Or with
one of the women. Then maybe. And I do think we're plausibly
going to get there or possibly going to get there with the Hebomaru
girl. But it seems like he was very often misrepresenting what
he was looking for intentionally. Okay. >> It's true it's
entirely about this, but that doesn't mean that I was I was I
was trying to do a ruse or whatever. That's that's outrageous.
Bang. >> And then he would flip on this. It's important
to be uh on the in the middle here and just just call it out
for what it is. If it's a If you're buzzwording, you're buzzwording
it. So, he would like he would not like this this happening to
him. So, don't greenlight it when it happens to other people.
>> Biggest victim of all of this is his
She is the biggest victim of all of it. Is that this guy was
playing around doing this disrespect >> Why is he going
for a second run through this? He watched He watched run one
run and now he's going for a second run. Does he think he's going
to be less incorrect or Asmongold's going to disagree less if
he watches the clip >> respecting her the entire time.
>> Guys, what if I said that all of his OTK um mates are
all victims of this uh person who's evil because he's doing some
financial sabotage by being part of OTK and trolling [laughter]
the game by making these wild takes and pretty much damaging
the whole org down by by tarnishing their name and making sure
that their income is is scuffed over and all the people that
work there are victims of of of him.
>> By intentional sabotage.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa, guys. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, you
can't say that. Whoa, whoa, you can't do you can't you can't
do this. This is insane. >> No, I think he would just agree
with that. I literally think So, what I think Asmongold just
argued was Asmongold says his
OTK loses sponsorships, they make less money. All the OTK members
say they're victims of Asmongold. I think Asmongold would just
say, "Yeah, they are." I say dumb [__] sponsors leave.
I actually think Asmongold would just go, "Yeah, they are victims
of me and and my big fat mouth."
Sorry, that's why I left. That's literally why he left OTK and
like that's why he has dropped a bunch of that stuff is cuz he
doesn't want to affect other people's opportunities.
then then I would be even more correct in what I'm saying than
what they're But now it's not okay to say that? No, I >> I'm
almost positive that if I could see like maybe Asmongold reacted
to this today and he could. I haven't I haven't actually checked.
It's entirely possible Asmongold reacted to this today cuz I
think he would react to it and say
yeah, that would be fine. Yeah, I'd be fine with that. They are
victims of me. >> I do the whole thing. Use the word use
the correct words when it applies and don't use words that you
know for a fact will be seen as one thing when presenting another
situation
because that makes people will now will see victim and they'll
say, "That's what I whatever." It could be just one guy that's
talking to some girls. Oh, it could be some victim could be just
some guy that Oh, it could be just a big creator talking. Now,
you you you're making the victim lose power. That that power
loses its fuel, yo. That's stupid. That's I disagree with this
entirely. Sorry.
>> genuinely really mean it. It seemed like middle schooler
drama.
basically not enough social skills to pick up on bantering. >> You
know what's >> like some >> Wait, who was it? The
the with the with >> Predator Simmons is more legit. Yeah,
>> Dude, his uh his girlfriend argued with
>> Yeah, I see I Well, I mean see her tweet. I was actually
right there. If you say victims rather than victim, it paints
us as it uh through the predators, Simmons is more legit. Yeah,
true. I mean just true. True, true, and all true. Yeah, true.
True, true. That's Rachel. >> I'm So, people could just
look into it and see that they mean something different. Literally,
this is the whole point of the discourse of like talking through
it.
I That's all you got to do is just you talk through it.
Nobody I Just find how many people actually the press the impression
that Sykkuno multiple women. Is that
Is that anywhere? Is Sykkuno canceled
Is there any amount of canceling that's
Or is this all hypothetical? >> You are right. There are
no victim >> Like if anything, Sykkuno has benefited massively
from this coming out.
That like there will be an an audience that will start showing
up to that he's not going to like it. It's not going to be the
same kind of audience he likes to slide into the DMs of, but
they'll be there.